départ mais alors comment vous l'idée
d'associer au pendule de foucault les
templiers les rose-croix les jésuites la
kabbale le jeu hitler bref c'est
incroyable votre roman vous aimez gary
idée d'associer tout ça vient de soi
ah bon tout cela aussi parce que mon
livre d'un réalisme
forcément je n'ai rien inventé et la
fonction des ses exergue qui lie à haut
début du chapitre qui pourrait paraître
comme un coquetterie de rue du scion ont
la fonction de dire écoutez monsieur si
vous croyez qu'ils étaient en vente
quelque chose d'incroyable contrôler il
ya eu toujours quelqu'un qui a dit
quelque chose de semblable ou de pire
jeudi la question va renouer chercher
dans les rayons de librairies poussé
rasées dans la tradition de la spéciale
mans dernier deux siècles de
l'occultisme on trouve on trouve tout et
tout est romanesque mais ce qui est ce
que pour moi et et romanesque s'était en
effet l'abondance de cette circulation
de surinterprétation surinterprétation
surinterprétation c'était le météorite
géante de livres
mon nom il a dit il mais pas là mais ça
ne veut dire yen il y aura toujours des
gens qui iront le chercher
ils trouveront des raisons pour croire
qu'il existe même si monsieur mono à
démontrer et c'est une équipe ne cherche
ni alors qu'il ya peu de téléspectateurs
évidemment qui dit mono a cherché
pendant très longtemps
une météorite est énorme qui s'est
écrasé dans le désert du sahara
et puis la fête populaire l'expédition
qui ne l'a jamais trouvées et pour la
pointe dans ce livre il dit que cette
fois il pense qu'elle n'a jamais existé
et mais il n'empêche lire encore des
gens après vous qui continueront ils à
raison d'un au gala rachetant d'autres
diront la météorite que n'a pas trouvé
que vous n'avez pas trouvé il existe
quand même quelque part les disques
voilà faut continuer et c'est comme et
comme le trésor des templiers oui parce
que si le professeur l'avait trouvée
c'était fini voilà ce n est plus
intéressant ce le fait le fait même
qu'il n'existe pas qui les rendent
intéressant oui les rangs de fascinant
ça n'en parle et non pas le scientifique
mais par les autres alors ce qui est
unique dans votre livre c'est que à
votre immense culture phénoménal vous
ajoutez une imagination débridée car bon
c'est vrai que vous faites l'alliance
dans ce livre à la fois de lait des
sciences occultes et de l'ordinateur est
il ce roman aurait pu s'intituler je
voudrais qu'on vous le dit à un moment
il va s'intituler apple et la kabbale où
il aurait pu s'intituler chez pas
l'ordinateur et les templiers donc
mélanger tous à la science la plus
moderne avec les ordinateurs et puis les
croyances les plus occulte les plus à la
messe et chora qui pourrait nous dire
que l'ordinateur n'a rien inventé les
rabbin cabaliste avait déjà et déjà
penser tout ça dans le roman je raconte
une histoire jeudi il y as librairie à
paris houplin vitrine de gauche c'est
ordinateur l'avait-elle
droite et cabaye c'est vrai elles
existent je peux vous la montrer mais
c'est pas par hasard c'est pas par
hasard
l'idée de la permutation de lettres qui
est à la base de ce programme le plus
élémentaire d'un ordinateur s'était dit
nous le disions tout à l'heure
l'occidental a tendance à voir des
objets là où l'oriental suppression
leucémiques voit des signes et le mot
signe en hébreu ces autres pluriel hot
hot et en arabe
hayat et le signe désigne la lettre la
lettre créatrice de tous et désigne
également le miracle et c'est par les
signes que le monde écrit que l'univers
est créé sur tout l'univers mental c'est
une vérité d'évidence canton ça c'est le
lien avec votre premier roman c'est il
est vrai que quand on s'approche d'un
secret quand on veut percer ce secret et
surtout s'il s'agit du de secret
fondateur de la société ou du monde on
risque sa vie c'est évident donc il ya
des personnages dans ce roman qui
risquent leur vie et certains d'ailleurs
vont vont la perdre mais je me dis que
mal que vous quand même vous êtes bien
en vie quand même
normalement vous devriez être une
victime de votre livre vous ne devriez
pas être là vous devriez y est mort
attendez le moins du temps trentaine
d'années au moins ben oui parce que vous
percer un secret le secret du oui je
vous en prie non il n'y a pas de secret
important dans mon livre il ya des gens
qui qui qui cherchent un faux secret
mais oui mais j'insiste sur ce fait et
il y as année c'est degers email
donc cela également le début du siècle
sur la fonction que le secret peut jouer
dans tout le jeu de pouvoir est le
secret le plus forte
c'est lui avec lesquels on fait des jeux
de domination des dominations cdc créé
vite parce qu'il ya le secret dans
l'essence de l'inconnu qui est de secret
chercher par les scientifiques
peu à peu on trouvera quelque chose il y
a le secret métaphysique religieux c'est
le show a créé c'est une espèce de
centre autour duquel la recherche
tourner
après il y adeux secret qui est
d'habitude les secrets des services
secrets sont forts parce qu'ils n'ont
qu'en secret parce qu'il sait en avait
un il le par train immédiatement mais
ils font semblant 8 son semblant
semblant donc le secret de plus terrible
et les secrets qui n'existe pas et qui
est manoeuvrer manié par quelqu'un pour
pour convaincre les autres qui lie à
l'existant il y à un central dans mon
livre l'histoire des protocoles des
sages de sion c'est l'invention d'un
plan secret pour avoir pouvoir et pour
détruire à détruire un ennemi mais ce
qui était important mais il n'y a pas de
secret si vous allez lire les protocoles
des sages de sion
ils disent des bêtises de banalité que
tout le monde connaît oui mais en même
temps il y avait une sorte de je dirais
de nécessité presque biologique et
métaphysique de croire à un secret je
conteste c'est enfantin c'est l'enfant
qui dit à l'autre enfant à aa avec un
petit coup de cette chose
nous autres nous adultes nous avons je
crois c'est typique de la culture de la
séance de lattes la vie de dire à tout
le monde ce que nous savons nous ne
voulons pas avoir des secrets la science
ne veut pas avoir des sacres la la la la
théologie ne veut pas avoir des secrets
elle veut dire il ya quelque chose qui
est au delà de notre connaissance
mais ce n'est pas un secret oui mais
tous vos personnages y vivent de ce
secret et certains même vont en mourir
mais il est il ce secret qui n'existe
pas mais vous
il ya une superbe définition qui a été
donné par gérard meudal dans libération
il a dit alors ils parlent du syllogisme
de votre livre jeudi qu'il existe une
société secrète avec des ramifications
dans le monde entier et qui complotent
pour répandre la rumeur qu'il existe un
complot universel
ce n'est pas une invention était vrai il
a été vrai beaucoup de fois d'inde dans
l'histoire mais au fond ce qui est vrai
c'est que vous êtes un vrai romantique
et parce que vous aimez les héros
l'impression que vous aimez dans votre
nom de la rose et b to c moines qui
étaient des héros et là aussi il ya
trois héros qui sont des éditeurs vous
vous aimez les roues héros de bande
dessinée parce que votre livre pour être
aussi il n'ya pas de dessin mais il
pourrait être une bande dessinée paul
longue
oui mais un peu long très long il ya en
plusieurs volumes certaines oui je les
aime
autrement pourquoi perdre tout ce temps
là est calé mais vous dit le héros dans
les cent deux protagonistes dans les
sens des protagonistes héroïque 90
protagonistes protagonistes et qui peut
parfois être héroïques où certains
l'oeil d'ailleurs assez héroïque dans
votre livre il est assez lâche sainement
lâche pour devenir le véritable grosse
que les lâches qu'ils sont capables de
dominer mais par exemple un héros dont
parle beaucoup actuellement en france
parce qu'à la fois il est au cinéma et
au théâtre c'est cyrano de bergerac
vous connaissez si bien sûr je suis
dioula secteur vous connaissez tous
leurs banques dont nous nous servons
bergeron mais pas tous c'est le livre de
mon enfance si on nous dira si un autre
berger a et demain je vais j'ai moment
l'éditeur a fait tout pour trouver un
bon vous avez non non je veux voir tout
les serrano condor monde
je connais pas par coeur soit le tir au
texte français soit la traduction
italienne qui est d'une beauté
extraordinaire à dunes et un en italie
inter d'unités jcb pas qu'à cause ce
n'est pas tel andy genève à new york à
ses côtés à pontacq à dire minton
agressive a sauvé son cottage
immédiatemment aimer l'opéra italien qui
est vrai qu'on est capable depuis 12 ans
à vous reconnais j'ai rêvé toute ma vie
d'avoir ma roxane de mourir comme cyrano
et voyez moi un crack